[Música]
sou jovem super conectado e não só nas
redes sociais é super blogueiro mas não
só nas redes sociais e na comunidade
também né
e essa foto é uma das últimas um dos
meus últimos post integra a legenda que
legal que agora é o momento da favela
sabe é isso mas eu chego nessa nessa
história vai mais na frente mas é como
já valeu moradores das comunidades para
a dona da vila não são lucas que foi a
última vila a entrar pro mapa do
aglomerado da serra para quem não tem
ligado à câmara da serra bem pertinho do
centro dessas periferias que são mais
próximas ao centro
a gente tem um certo tipo de privilégio
é por poder procurar emprego a pé
estudar em uma escola que seja em um
bairro na periferia e sempre tive
extremamente conectado né com o morro e
asfalto e dessa maneira portali no
aglomerado da serra
a gente está bem no finalzinho da
primeira da série a favelinha é bem no
finalzinho né é engraçado porque mesmo
hoje em dia eu sendo é um homem branco
hétero às vezes mas a gente tem o tempo
todo que ficar provando que esse lugar
que a gente vem é um lugar legal que a
gente é legal que eu não sou ladrão
começou agora imagina ontem dançarino
que tivesse um homem negro gay dançarina
de funk já imagina o tanto que ele tem
que provar mais ainda para a sociedade
que ele é legal né esse lugar onde as
pessoas vêm dá pra ver que é tudo
extremamente conectado é tudo eu tenho
vizinhos era a gente tem visto em baixo
de um lado na frente e outra atrás e a
guerra às drogas
a tal da guerra às drogas não é uma
guerra às drogas é uma guerra o povo da
favela que a gente vê o tempo todo que
nesse lugar extremamente conectado a
polícia está lá agir de uma forma
truculenta que a polícia é lenta
e truculenta demora e quando vai estar
às e por conta dessa parcela da
população a gente é o tempo todo tido
como um lugar sem luz
o lugar de difícil acesso lugar de
ignorância né eu muito pelo contrário só
vejo luz só vejo cor nesse lugar o tempo
todo as dos lugares mais maravilhosa do
mundo dos lugares onde tenha liberdade e
nesse lugar nesse celeiro eu me formei
artista desde cedo eu descobri que eu
não queria aquela coisa única
sabe uniforme carteira de escola achava
aquilo tudo sabe parece um trabalho a
sirene eficientes aquela boca era pra
frente
não eu sempre da criatividade da família
mas é uma luta da família começa a
ganhar dinheiro e jóias
é o empresário da família hoje em dia
mas nesse lugar de luz eu me descobri
como poeta e mais tarde eu comecei a
gravar minhas poesias
aí eu tive um momento muito interessante
da minha vida da minha carreira que foi
o duelo de mcs no centro de belo
horizonte bairro ponte todas as
sexta-feiras todas as periferias se
encontravam nesse lugar pra fazer rima
nem cantar eu tinhas e desenho sempre
muito empreendedor eu ia gravar cd e no
computador escrevia na mão o endereço
eletrônico e vendiam por 32 por cinco e
tal e nesse lugar foi muito interessante
que eu tive um palco pra eu ser um
protagonista da minha própria história
então com 17 anos na escola não era só
mais um tablet nacional mcl do viaduto
pede a rima e pede a palavra e eu faço a
rima e é muito legal isso e eu tive essa
oportunidade de petra sender eu digo
assim esse espaço onde todo mundo
trabalha imaginado mas dá hoje artista e
o palco do duelo ficou muito pequeno pra
mim eu queria um sarau de poesias na
época carlos araújo relata o dirigente
de 15 em 15 dias reunir jovens nas
praças públicas para falar e ouvir
poesia assim o dedo vegetariano sede
social 70 mas a gente está ali na praça
ocupando fazendo essa poesia
graças a essa poesia entre fugir ao
mundo do teatro de bonecos
eu comecei a trabalhar com a galera
inicialmente na composição de uma trilha
sonora e mais tarde eu entrei pra ele
de marionetes e viaja o brasil inteiro e
era legal que iniciou já estava cantando
meus próprios então teatro acaba dez
horas da noite eu estava lá em belém do
pará eu conseguir sair do teatro vem de
um show de rap início fiz no brasil
inteiro e também dava uma oficina de ímã
para o estado
isso eu tinha 23 e 24 24 anos tinha um
cabelão dread gigante sentada só terás
na pisa sem fim sem aluguel jovem assim
sabe todo jovem
gostaria de estar naquele momento
naquela posição só que quando eu voltava
pra minha rua a minha galera que cresceu
comigo pessoas tão interessantes quanto
então potenciais tanto e não só de arte
na época na favela tem sua ajuda em tudo
parece que percebem que isso tem que
sacar em alguma coisa né
pessoas que se destacavam em alguma
coisa estava envolvido com as práticas
de violência urbana é engravidando antes
da hora e sempre no sub emprego tem
pessoas tão talentosas até mais
talentosos que eu quem repositor de
supermercado nada contra o reprodutor
supermercado mas sempre só vai sobrar
isso preferia adequando né até que eu
criei meu primeiro empreendimento que é
o lado da favelinha eu tava eu estava
muito triste nessa época pra falar a
verdade porque eu cantava e estava
ganhando grana legal diário de natação
lá esperava
só quando voltar vou quebrar eu fiz e me
senti meio pode assim depois que está
cantando brincando de boneco grande de
rio branco claudina não vou fazer alguma
coisa que dentro da minha comunidade
então o lado a favelinha essa casinha
porque realmente era só isso mudou
era só isso e era para ser só uma
biblioteca e oficina de rep
no primeiro evento que eu fiz pra
divulgar essas oficinas de rap num lugar
que é menor que esse palco cada 50
pessoas confortáveis
a gente recebeu mais de mil pessoas
imagina se instalar na viela de seu
barraco e mil pessoas chega extremamente
interessante da equipa e tudo mais nessa
acreditar e gente viu que não era só uma
biblioteca e oficina de rap
isso eu comecei a abrir as portas à
comunidade chamar voluntários para dar
oficinas hoje em dia a gente tem o
ensino de espanhol do espanhol e inglês
capoeira artesanato rep passinho que
está bombando é e yoga e órgãos são só
para as mamães gente várias mais na
segunda feira 8 da manhã fazendo a
saudação para a lua de cabeça pra baixo
e ficando a semana tudo bem tranquila
hoje em dia nós temos 16 oficinas e essa
logo acaba de se tornar uma associação
que é a parte criativa a parte
educacional da favelinha uma parte né é
a parte mas mais comunismo eu vou falar
do capitalismo agora da favelinha que é
essa outra marca que está tatuada no
braço que é onde a gente começou a gerar
renda porque gera renda eu só tinha um
aluguel e na época eu comecei falando
esse dinheiro tinha grana então eu
consegui segurar 16 meses mas aí o
teatro parou de vender eu parei de
cantar eu achei um absurdo que estava
fazendo e tive que repetir na minha
carreira
o estado me mandou embora a opção que eu
fazia uns acharam nunca dava dinheiro só
dá problema para a gente fazer essa rota
bem e decidi focar na campanha não tinha
grana eu fiz um primeiro financiamento
coletivo que eu sempre conectado às
redes sociais que a gente pra caramba e
no primeiro treinamento coletivo
precisava de 15 mil reais
olha que pouco 15 mil reais para deixar
um ano aberto tendo água luz aluguel
lanche para as oficinas e o aluguel de
pasto mas eu fiz um financiamento
coletivo de arrecadar 17 mil reais
deságio de 15 a 16 por um ano tranquilo
mas empreendedores ou claro que não
queria ficar o resto da vida pedindo
dinheiro que usou a internet
eu comecei a criar outros rolês o
primeiro que foi um dos mais
interessantes é a disputa nervosa quem
já viu a sua tarefa é incrível a batalha
do passinho ski que acontece na disputa
nervosa eu pego um dançarino uma
dançarina e outro em frente ele tem 45
segundos pra dialogar ele nem na dança
do ventre duelo de mc's então isso
sempre foi muito interessante que é pra
ver quem é o melhor pra ver quem é
melhor para si mesmo que vai ter de
atacar mais e mais criativo ea disputa
nervosa nasceu de uma brincadeira total
e a gente começou na seqüência vender
para grandes festivais super engraçado
que não há segundo show foi no festival
a última fit festival internacional de
teatro
e aí os meninos jogar em casa e falar em
mudança na fia de hoje foi barato tudo
mas eles dançaram uma vez no palácio das
artes
nem sei porque falam de marli 0 com a
marca lá né da webjet a eles passavam em
frente palazza aqui que é aquele evento
é o meu palácio das artes o grande chato
falar da disputa nervoso começou a ser
muito interessante que eles começaram a
se encontrar mais eu comecei a unir as
periferias de belo horizonte e vários
lugares diferente e começou a gerar
muita renda
ano passado a gente teve no breve no
mesmo palco que também vê luz para
evitar benesses sem querer falar que o
show foi melhor ou pior mas a disputa é
tão verdadeira que conecta imediatamente
com as pessoas
a platéia opina que vai ganhar quem vai
perder então fica um sentimento de
pertencimento tão grande enfim esse ano
a gente já tá pra quem começou com nada
nesse ano a gente já entrou com 250 mil
reais para fazer a captação de disputa
nervosa nacional então vai ter aqui em
belo horizonte uma disputa com os oito
melhores dançarinos os oito melhores
times partindo do ano né desse ano aqui
em belo horizonte está muito mas a
disputa negócios foi um dos meus
primeiros empreendimentos do super certo
e tem roupa pra eu creio favelinha
fashion week gente esse é o barato que
que aconteceu não sei falar inglês virou
a mesa nem sabia que o henrique era
semana alguém falando seria favelinha
fashion day ou não quem o ipn aparecer
são paulo fashion week e tal
e lá no morro tem um beco chama
passarela ea diversidade da beleza da
favela é tão incrível que as pessoas
começaram a me procurar para fazer
casting de elenco e falou assim eu
preciso de um anão negro oriental de
dredd cabelo vermelho
eu vou achar na favela sempre vai haver
menos gente pinta e eu descobri que
tinha um beco passarela eu tinha as
pessoas mais lindas do mundo de todos os
periódicos à minha disposição ea galera
bem azul galé brasil precisa né
eu tinha três modelos de chanti três
modelos de boné e um bazar que gerava
sustentabilidade do nosso lanche das
oficinas da gente fez um acervo com
bazar com essas chutes e pegaram outras
roupas de marcas locais e lançamos o
favela chic no beco passarela
mais uma vez eu não sabia
que acontecer e jornais de moda começar
a procurar gente a gente não sei de nada
a ver com a composição do inverno
outubro de 2001
não sei de que fala a gente vai testar e
vencer mas tal a gente começou a vender
esse evento e é sempre um evento muito
legal que dá muito trabalho que tem que
fazer uma lista é cabelo
ok chinelo calça doc maquiar jockey a
menina vai comer em outro lugar não é um
caos mas é muito legal esse evento em
que vê e entramos nesse ano com um
projeto aí não posso falar a marca
quanto de contrato mas com uma galera de
londres e uma galera daqui de minas e um
projeto aprovado em meio milhão de reais
que é pra fazer o garoto a hacker que é
onde recorde para mulheres não brancas e
quem faz boa parte dessas roupas são as
mulheres não brancos da comunidade e vai
ter desfile família fechei que em bh são
paulo rio e londres beleza favelinha
fashion week estava criado daí veio o
remédio gente remexe maravilhoso remexe
é seguir a onda da moda a gente pega
existentes e faz uma nova roupa por
exemplo temos é puxa jeans feita de
calça jeans e mochila jeans é vendida
por 99 reais
a gata que fez um estilo jeans ganha 50
reais início a gente faz de tudo caso o
chiba né papa e gera muita renda no
posicionamento que eu já paguei muita
gente tenta então vamos seguir
eu criei mais tarde o favelinha dance
porque a galera do funk estava incrível
criando pesquisando e estudando e de
gente boa gente tipos de palco e o povo
começou a fazer é de 15 anos faz
formatura serem da gente acabou de
chegar de um final de semana tipo
governador valadares rio de janeiro hoje
aqui daqui a pouco estão em proteger ou
galera ganhando mais salário mínimo por
mês no carnaval de chegar mais três mil
reais balança na bunda sabe são quatro
dançarinos de periferias a gente chama
mais eu acho que eles estão por aí que
eu vou resolver favelinha dance e virou
mais que um grupo a cooperativa a gente
dá aula também um deles vai download
enfim aulas particulares né
aí eu queria fazer um shopping center
que eu tinha tanta coisa pra vender que
tinha que escoar
essa produção inclusive essa blusa que
estou usando está sendo vendida lá fora
viu pra quem tá na internet só pegar um
link que vai aparecer aqui embaixo
e essa busca está usando é ela financia
os estudos do edson silva que está por
aqui são vários recordes de blues dele
ele é morador de perth também negro lá
do morro das pedras está ajudando arte
design marcelle no sul da frança e
metade essa grana do lucro vai para ele
sem dar para comprar um pãozinho francês
na conversa o dinheiro mas o velho
shopping center superengraçado pelo
interessante que é uma bandinha ou
online imóvel ea gente está sobrevivendo
e esse ano nas lojas física
daí eu queria ele também fica rica
favelinha fica com carrick y esse que eu
fui fazer lá em londres que palestra
empreendedorismo ensinar a galera gerir
o tempo e gerar renda a partir dos
próprios conhecimentos principalmente se
for de comunidade né
e por fim eu creio formação de quadrilha
porque formação de quadrilha porque se
você bate aglomerado da serra no youtube
até então a gente está começando pelo
stop porque o amor vence a violência a
gente com certeza estou falando de
dinheiro e tudo mais que eu tenha falado
de manhã a falar o que não é visto não é
aceitável mas é muito amor mesmo sabe o
amor vence o ódio a gente está começando
a vencer e essa é uma prova grande que
quando você bate você vai ver quadrilha
e tráfico e crimes sem gente não é assim
saber de janeira para papai noel lazer
assim sabe a comunidade às vezes acho
que até tem muita mídia na serra
palmital usar essas outras quebrada é
bem mais violenta eo povo fica focado na
serra não sei que a gente criou formação
de quadrilha que é o que o são joão a
nossa são joão a gente dança faz as
próprias roupas eu vou contar um caso
rapidinho que é o seguinte em um de são
joão um dos nossos maiores problemas de
diálogo é a polícia é essa tal que
enfrenta o combate às drogas eo policial
não conhecia quando eu fui pedir o
alvará e sei lá o quê já tive a irmã
dela aí não vou poder liberar o alvará
porque essa festa que vai virar baile
funk com o problema porque a gente não
preserva as mesmas estruturas de 20 mil
reais e fazer essa festa pessoal festa
junina que a verba total juros o cume
cândido na favela
de 20 mil mas voltei para quebrada
triste
daí os líderes do tráfico para vincar
que a gente vai pagar essa festa ele não
aceite 30 20 mil né na crise não já
enfiei na crise vai causar 20 mil
recusei no dia seguinte os mandaram me
chamar eu já fui piedade de quando
chegou a instalar ou muito bonita essa
atitude silva mas a gente tem uns
vestidos para haidê moroni que a gente
aí uma época eles em operação a
quadrilha que de errado a gente tem
investido gente pode nova demorou nem o
cpf ou o cnpj então manda pra nós
existir que a gente e deu supercerto
eliana a gente fez a festa na vitória e
no ano seguinte veio a idéia de trazer o
remédio pra dentro formação de quadrilha
então eu era muito mas eu também tinha
um cano que vazava muita água e as
meninas ficavam lá não vai sujar meu pé
foi a gente foi consertar o cano natural
com prêmio joela consertar o cano que
seria da copasa demais e para outros já
os pés das meninas hoje em dia a gente
tem patrocínio da melissa pra fazer essa
festa da briga alagoas abrigar o que
quero da minha lista do mais por fim e
aquilo que era bem pequenininho lado da
favelinha ficou gigante que ano passado
a gente precisou ampliar nosso espaço e
nosso espaço que cabia 50 pessoas
confortáveis haverá esse prédio
supermacio aglomerado da serra foi feito
com vaquinha também e reunir 112 mil
reais de 10 em 10 50 e 50 reais de cada
um e vai ser um espaço super legal onde
a gente vai ter vestiários o lugar onde
a galera dança onde vai ter o favelinha
shopping center teto verde e tudo mais e
é isso é pegar e fazer não esperar que
tem uma poesia que dialoga muito com o
tema disse ted e com esse lado de pegar
fazer três anos assim
essa cidade é muito grande meus sonhos
não estão distantes não enxerga a
realidade quando eu comparo com antes
respeito é pra quem tem na rua morro ao
asfalto na praça igreja boteco sempre
tem que falar alto oportunidade assalto
tanto quanto é assaltado conselho de
estado errado eu escuto por todo lado
circuito da defraudado tirada jogo de
dados recado pregado ao lado da minha
foto procurado e guarda três por quatro
fato evolução contínua continua enquanto
viver cuidado com a rotina com crack com
coco
ainda vizinhos desconhecidos esquiva se
de inveja de tudo o que é corrompido ame
sua família desde a sua filha separar o
joio do trigo e também o milho verde
onde tem deus meu pai minha mãe meu
talento meu tesouro hoje todo o compõem
e ele sabe o valor do ouro definir se é
calouro chapadão e divido essa na hora
do estouro que ninguém fala duvido
duvido é será no campo e jazz em bh e
não tem praia na estação ipanema os
arcos santa teresa o livro está sobre a
mesa só quem abre estudo enxerga chuchu
beleza
salve mãe natureza água fresca com
pureza para o meu neto bisneto no feto
na correnteza
salve santa teresa salve salve santa
lúcia salve cosme damião 3 mil ursinhos
de pelúcia jesus consagrara fala me
livra da polícia de tiro de perícia sua
bala chita e delícia só de ti vem a
justiça correta de próprio punho eu
escrevo guarda o rascunho de encher
linguiça sai de mim pesquisa feitiço do
esquisito acorda com a voz bonita pronto
para fazer bonito me guia me capacita
protege tanto me inspira me da mulher
bonita que não é chegada em briga em
nossas barriga de todos que necessita
proteger meus amiguinhos
amém é nóis na fita valeu